in the 1980s he was homeless while he
tried to raise his toddler son to get
off the streets he became a stockbroker
and later an entrepreneur today he is
worth millions and had Will Smith play
him in a movie he's Chris Gardner
and here are his top ten rules for
success you gotta have a plan
everybody's got a dream
everybody's got a goal what's the plan
and your plan has got to have something
I call the c5 complex your plan has got
to be clear concise compelling
consistent and committed you've got to
have a plan and when you're trying to do
something that you are truly passionate
about there is no plan B okay Plan B
sucks all right
okay so it's as simple as that you got
to have a plan I mean think about that
for a second mm three examples Michael
Jordan won six NBA championships with
the Chicago Bulls because he was
committed to plant a not plan B Oprah
Winfrey became the queen of all media
because she was committed to plan a not
Plan B whatever your politics are Barack
Obama is sitting in the White House
because he was committed to plan a not
Plan B okay Plan B sucks work for me
regarding balance between family and
business opportunities was always to be
mindful of in a tie family comes first
my child always came first have you've
managed your relationships properly the
business presentation you're so
concerned about the big conference call
it that cannot happen without you on the
phone all those things can be
rescheduled but your son is going to
have one first baseball game the
daughter is going to have one first
dance recital and you've got to be there
in a tie family wins I made in my mind
as a young guy I wanted to become
world-class as something I just had to
find out what that something was going
to be and the very first time that I
walked into a Wall Street trading room I
knew this is it the ticker tape is
rolling
the phones are ringing off the hook
people are screaming and shouting out
orders bodies are flying all over the
place it will look like chaos to anybody
else I could see the natural rhythm in
it it was like I was reading a sheet of
music and I knew this is where I'm
supposed to be I kept coming back I wore
one branch manager down to the point
that he says to me Gardner based on
persistence alone we go give you a shot
man I quit my job that was all I wanted
I went home and I told my ex you know
what you said I couldn't do it but guess
what I started two weeks too many of us
for a long
have confused our net worth and our
self-worth your net worth is going to
fluctuate it's going to go up and down
that's what money does but your
self-worth should not who you are what's
important to you how you live your
values should never be negotiable
compromised and should never settle
again we have gotten to this point where
we've got to say to ourselves my net
worth is not my self-worth employees I
believe is number one you gotta respect
them let them roll and you got to trust
them and leave them alone and you have
to also show them the opportunity to
make more money than they've ever made
in their lives all that combined that's
how you motivate your key core employees
are you lookin to instigate a change in
your life there's no better or worse
time than right now hi I understand
change is scary with the status quo you
know what you've got and you shake
things up there's no telling what you
might end up with but two of the things
are true about change one is absolutely
necessary for personal growth and two is
gonna happen either you can pick the
time to instigate the change you want or
the change and the time will pick you so
if you happen to be one of those people
who's standing on the sidelines of your
dreams waiting for that perfect moment
if you want to make that change but you
just don't know if you're ready this
life lesson is for you it's time to stop
digging your potatoes and jump baby
steps count - as long as you're going
forward and one day you had all those
baby steps up and you might be surprised
at where you can get to but more
importantly I remember something my mom
used to say to me every day she would
say son the cavalry ain't coming you got
to do this yourself ain't no backup
okay then when you put those two things
together man it wasn't as hard to keep
going forward as you might think well
now that we can see how short life
really can be what are you going to do
with the rest of your life that's a
trigger that's the biggest trigger that
I have ever experienced what are you
going to do the rest of your life and
what I had to do is I had to start
taking some of my own advice I have been
telling people I had written about it
for a very long time that if you're
doing something that you're not totally
committed to if you're doing something
that you're not totally passionate about
you're compromising yourself every day I
was presentable but I wore the same two
suits and I had two suits man that I had
to wear every day for a year
one blue one gray the joke around the
office started oh that's Chris gardener
he's reenacting the Civil War some days
what the north some days he's with the
South I'll never forget a recent
experience
doing my business on Wall Street getting
on the train to come back to midtown one
o'clock in the afternoon normally
there's a low this train should be empty
but on this day the train was full full
of people all in business sees a guy
recognizes me comes over and says hey
are you Chris Gardner we started talking
turns out I'm in the car with the first
wave of the 55,000 people who had just
been laid off by Citibank and I noticed
something everyone's holding a box
you've seen the boxes you've seen them
on television they've got the houseplant
the coffee mug the pictures of their
kids and they're all going home they're
all going home to tell their wife their
husband their children and the landlord
they don't have a job I began to share
with this young guy that do you know
what yeah you lost your job but you
haven't lost your skills your talent or
your expertise but we've got to do now
is create opportunities where the
skilled talent and expertise can be
transferable creating an opportunity and
looking for a job are two different
things
this could be prime time for pushing
your button rather finding your button
what do I mean by that prime time to
find that one thing that you love to do
so much you would get up in the morning
and do it free prime time to find that
one thing that the Sun cannot comes up
soon enough in the morning because you
want to go do your thing
this could be that time in your life
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because arsh solutions asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do